[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que hoy nos
lleva a varios a la costa este de chipre
que se ha convertido en una ciudad
fantasma era uno de los balnearios más
elegantes del meditarráneo en los años
1950 1960 estrellas como elizabeth
taylor y richard burton o brigitte
bardot frecuentaban sus hoteles y playas
pero hoy se está desmoronando chipre es
sin embargo una de las islas más
hermosas del mediterráneo bañada por la
historia los asirios los helenos los
persas y los romanos dejaron sus huellas
pero después de su independencia hasta
la segunda guerra mundial la isla se
convirtió en una apuesta en la rivalidad
entre turquía y grecia en sangrientos
enfrentamientos comunitarios en 1974
estalló un golpe de estado militar
apoyado por los coroneles griegos de
respuesta el ejército turco invadió el
norte de chipre incluyendo barosa omar
hache para los turcos desde hace casi
medio siglo la isla está dividida en dos
el norte dirigido por un gobierno turco
chipriota y en el sur la república de
chipre el único estado reconocido por la
comunidad internacional y miembro
en cuanto a brocha el acceso a la ciudad
está abierto unas horas al día algunos
turistas y antiguos habitantes eran a
descubrir la ciudad abandonada que es un
poco un símbolo de todos los problemas
de la isla según una resolución de la
onu pero ya debe ser devuelta a sus
propietarios originales pero ni las
autoridades grecochipriotas y la
administración turco chipriota se han
puesto de acuerdo para aplicar esta
medida
[Música]
se trata de una antigua estación
balnearia conocida en el mundo entero
actualmente en ruinas este hotel era uno
de los más notables
entonces aquí pueden ver el gol de
mariana cuando aún estaba en actividad
en aquella época los los dos una familia
chipriota griega eran los más grandes
propietarios de inmuebles de barossa
andreas el heredero tenía seis años
cuando las fuerzas turcas bombardearon
la ciudad
tenía una pistola de plástico y trataba
de defenderlos
guarde la pequeña pistola de plástico
hasta que abandonamos barosa
precipitadamente
los aviones militares nos bombardeaban y
mi madre muy preocupada nos decía que si
encontramos un avión militar detendré el
vehículo ustedes se bajan y regresaré a
buscar
andreas sigue reivindicando la propiedad
de este hotel que volvió a ver por
primera vez hace año y medio
igualmente a trato de ingresar al
apartamento donde vivió su infancia pero
fue detenido brevemente porque está
prohibido cruzar los límites de lo que
es considerado como una zona militar
les corts el tiempo pasarán ya pasó y
cada minuto fuera de nuestro hogar nos
hace daño
sólo queremos regresar a casa y vivir en
paz
en bar o si el tiempo se detuvo hace 48
años en
1974 el ejército turco no había previsto
apropiarse de la estación balnearia pero
como sus habitantes habían huido decidió
ocupar la
baros a omar arts para los turcos está
ubicada actualmente en la república
turca de chipre del norte la rtc m una
entidad no reconocida internacionalmente
es algo por ankara la ciudad acoge una
de las dos bases militares turcas de la
isla hasta 30.000 soldados turcos se
encontrarían aún ahí en octubre de 2020
dos calles fueron abiertas al público y
menos de un año más tarde el presidente
turco anunció que una parte de la ciudad
en adelante quedaría en manos de las
autoridades civiles chipriotas turcas el
consejo de seguridad de la onu ve una
provocación en ello los antiguos
residentes temen que con este cambio de
administración barosa ya no sea
transferida a las autoridades chipriotas
griegas en caso de acuerdo tal como
siempre ha estado previsto pero que sea
integrada a la rdc n recep tayip erdogán
prometió entonces un arreglo sobre el
asunto de las expropiaciones
la vida retornará amarás
las puertas de una nueva era
es aprovechar a todos a la luz de
estudios conformes al derecho de
propiedad
[Música]
serán abiertos del mar h
una especie de turismo de catástrofe es
desarrollado entonces con alquiler de
bicicletas cafés zonas de juegos y
terrenos de vóley playa en la sombra de
inmuebles vacíos que amenazan con
desplomarse
según ankara desde la reapertura parcial
de barossa hace un año y medio más de
400.000 visitantes han recorrido sus
calles calles que le pertenecerían todas
a una organización religiosa que existe
desde la era otomana skaf agrupa a más
de 2000 fundaciones en la isla el
profesor y brahím venter es su
presidente
mucho
lo que pueden ver es que todas las
tierras pertenecen a efe
según el profesor ska posee barro allá
desde 1571 cuando los otomanos tomaron
el control de la isla sostiene que el
derecho de propiedad de las fundaciones
o bad kids fue borrado deliberadamente
durante la era colonial británica desde
finales del siglo 19 hasta 1960
spot
este terreno pertenecía al bakhit de
abdulá para allá
y cuando llegamos en 1936
de repente el nombre de bakíev ya no es
mencionado en los círculos de
propiedades
en algunos terrenos tales como esta
mezquita que hizo renovar no son
disputados por la parte griega su
pertenencia a la fundación está
claramente establecida
para hacer reconocer sus derechos sobre
barosa cap apeló sin éxito ante la corte
europea de los derechos humanos
la fundación acudió entonces a una corte
de justicia en la parte chipriota turca
de nicosia la ipc
cuando abandonó la isla del antiguo
colono inglés pagó un millón y medio de
libras esterlinas a la administración
chipriota turca para indemnizar a ed cap
para el profesor venter ello no
significa que los terrenos cambiaron de
propietario
no son cien años mil años
es para siempre los terrenos va aquí no
pueden ser vendidos
no pueden ser regalados
bajo ninguna circunstancia una propiedad
va aquí puede cambiar de mano
es un argumento que los antiguos
habitantes de barossa rechazan
categóricamente
en particular la municipalidad en el
exilio de famagusta de la que barosa es
periferia la administración chipriota
griega de famagusta se instaló aquí en
mi va sol a 120 kilómetros al sur del
otro lado de la línea verde de la onu el
alcalde en el exilio hicimos joan o
sospecha que el cap sirve de fachada
para las reivindicaciones territoriales
de la parte turca de la isla
el problema es que tratan de arreglar el
contencioso
no de manera política sino de manera
legal
y entonces sacaron esa historia de ética
sanabdón del tema método
según una resolución de la onu de
1984 barosa debe ser regresada a sus
habitantes originarios una decisión
ignorada hasta ahora por los políticos
de los dos lados de la línea verde y que
tampoco ha sido aplicada por la onu
mercal a mí un analista político
chipriota turco nos hizo en el viejo
puerto de famagusta según él el célebre
barrio de barossa siempre ha sido usado
como una palanca de negociación
la posición chipriota turca era cuando
quieren alcanzar un acuerdo global se
los daremos pero comer sin tratar todo
cambio el problema más grande aquí es
que afirmamos que esta tierra nos
pertenece el lado chipriota turco dice
que está bajo su soberanía pero es falso
está bajo la soberanía de las fuerzas
militares turcas
los antiguos gobiernos de la parte turca
habían propuesto regresar a baroja a sus
habitantes varias veces pero en octubre
de 2020 el nacionalista sin tratar fue
elegido presidente de todos los
dirigentes del norte de la isla es el
más cercano ankara y su objetivo es que
la rtc n sea considerada como un estado
independiente y realizable según mercado
a mí
la manera en que la rtc n fue
establecida fue contraria a la ley
internacional en todas las etapas
entonces el reconocimiento sería
difícilmente justificable no sólo desde
un punto de vista legal sino también
político el principio fundamental en
este momento es que nada está decidido
hasta que todo esté decidido y nos
estamos retrasando porque ciertas élites
políticas deben su existencia tan solo a
su discurso sobre la división del país y
no su reunificación
cuando los otomanos desembarcan en el
puerto de famagusta en el siglo 16 la
mayoría de los habitantes cristianos de
lengua griega deben abandonar la ciudad
se refugian entonces en un nuevo barrio
barosa o periferia en turco
para los desplazados de
1974 la historia se repite anna marangu
vive en nicosia ella responsabiliza a
los políticos de las partes norte y sur
nosotros los fam agustia nos morimos
cada vez más
es tal vez por eso que el gobierno
espera para que ya no haya arraigos con
esta ciudad mi amigos
mis hijos y mis nietos seguro no tienen
la misma relación con la ciudad que yo
tengo la mía por ahora soy yo quien
lucha no sé por cuántos años más
en su biblioteca esta historiadora
conserva con cuidado los documentos de
su casa en bar osa
no doncel entonces esta es mi casa
dice que desde 1974 vemos famagusta
desde lejos
yo no lo llamo barosa
me gusta usar la palabra turca utilice
mucho monto un expediente ante la
comisión de las propiedades la empecé
hace más de diez años
este es 2011 y expediente y tengo esto y
esto y esto
mason y recibir la certificación de
propiedad de terreno ocupado por los
turcos no tengo mi título se quedó en
famagusta
a diferencia de la gran mayoría de los
refugiados que piden que su bien les sea
indemnizado anamar and go solicita la
restitución de su casa y dice que ella
quisiera vivir en ella incluso si barosa
debía seguir bajo control de la parte
turca no voy a encontrar mis libros
a mis padres lo que abandoné eso es
seguro será otra cosa pero hay varios
locos como yo
hay que ser un poco loca en la vida yo
quiero regresar a favor gusto shamah bot
más de 7000 expedientes fueron enviados
a la comisión de las propiedades desde
que fue establecida en el 2016 con el
aval de la comisión europea a los
derechos humanos los chipriotas griegos
forzados a huir de sus casas que se
encuentran ahora en regiones bajo
control de la república turca de chipre
del norte pueden solicitar restitución
indemnización o intercambio de propiedad
más de 1300 casos fueron juzgados pero
ninguno tiene relación con varios a una
simple coincidencia para la presidenta
de la comisión
en la ips no discriminamos según el
lugar
no decimos esto es un expediente de
magas
debemos tratarlo diferente si el
expediente está listo con todos los
documentos necesarios podemos tratarlo
pero los solicitantes deben hacerle
seguimiento a sus expedientes a
cada propiedad indemnizadas ahora está
en manos de la parte turca
los que esperan la reunificación de la
isla temen que el tribunal contribuya a
consolidar los cimientos territoriales
del norte y que desde entonces favorezca
una solución con dos estados
entonces anamar and go no esperó la
decisión de la comisión para actuar tal
como todos los fines de semana ella
conduces chipriotas griegos al norte de
la isla que acoge el 70 por ciento de
los sitios históricos
hoy en día varias decenas de personas
visitan una iglesia que se volvió museo
san bernabé nombre de quien evangelizó
la isla en el siglo primero
si hacemos que la juventud pueda
entender empezar a aceptar y amar este
patrimonio tal vez haya futuro
no es fácil por el momento hay que
insistir
pero persiste con estas visitas se
volvieron un medio para algunos de
aventurarse al norte por primera vez
desde hace años
yo hace 50 años que no venía de este
lado empecé la semana pasada el domingo
pasado fuimos a famagusta yo son del de
nueva forma gusta aún no he ido ya para
ver la catástrofe no creo tener el
coraje aún no hace falta tiempo para ir
anamar and go organiza estas excursiones
con un colega chipriota turco orhan
tolón él también desea poner el foco en
lo que une a los chipriotas en vez de
ponerlo en lo que divide
la cultura es más fuerte que la religión
o la lengua por supuesto los
nacionalistas o los políticos aún
insisten en nuestras religiones y
nuestras lenguas diferentes
pero como chipriota no se trata de cosas
importantes
estimulando el diálogo alrededor del
descubrimiento o el redescubrimiento de
un patrimonio común anna la chipriota
griega y ahora con el chipriota turco
esperan atraer a sus compatriotas al
camino de la reconciliación a lo largo
de los siglos esta isla estratégica no
ha cesado de ser invadida ocupada
colonizada reivindicada por una u otra
potencia del mediterráneo o de más allá
tanto hoy como ayer chipre enclave
europeo a las puertas de las costas del
medio oriente es objeto de mucho interés
[Música]
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a barbosa recuerde que
si quiere ver este y otros episodios en
español puede visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom hasta pronto